Yes you're saying the railway tech widens.
Yes. The only part that i had to deal
with the railways was at that stage.
The deck widens because it's the as i
said the arch foot wide and the brow about
a railway has to go out and past.
Whereas of course on the approach and
just a standard distance
apart the tracks are just
a standard but well i designed the
transition from the railway transition from
this the approaches on the south end to
the main span i did that transition
that we have for now. But
that's only part of the deal with the
railways across on the north side the same
problem doesn't arise because
you go straight into
a curve. And you are not there when they
were doing any of the original design so
that you didn't have anything to do with
that but did you do anything with the
preparation of any designs re the
whole bridge apart from that one.
Now. Well. Can we.
In those days when you were making
engineering calculations. What sort of quip
meant to do you have did you have
calculating machines or did you do
a slide rule of one which started off with
slide rules but that didn't last very
long. Bought. Calculating
machines and these
were hand operated you had to
turn a handle and also there was
a carrier which you had to move along. As
you passed from units to tens to hundreds
and so on. When you multiplied
because that was what is known as
a com tom itor. No that's
a trade name which they are ones. Where.
I'm sorry i can't remember the names it'll
come back to be they were we had choose
them after a couple of years
we got an electric type
a couple of electric types ones which
automatically transferred the carrier but
just still had to and you pressed a
button instead of landing and turning
a handle. But those
in red. There were
a calculator. How do you didn't have to
do into their thing by slide rule or in
your head or whatever they are if we got
those calculated we didn't slide rules we
used
a car. We had to forget how
many we had enough so that
you didn't have to use
a calculator all the time some calculation
i think you would still do by slide rule
but minor ones where you didn't get. Extreme
accuracy and so on but i think mainly
there were enough calculators. I don't
remember how many could have been more than
three or four do you remember dr.
Bradfield well did you come to know him
fairly well you know i only met him
a few times actually in the course of the
work he very rarely came into the office
and if we did it was mainly to talk to
gordon stuckey and just look around the
office but he wouldn't say it very rarely
speak to any of us. So what was your
impression of him. I can't
tell you i had no no
particular impression of him. What about
your dealings with the doorman long
started you haven't had anything to
do with him. No not really because
gordon stuckey handled the
dealings himself. Mainly.
Writing letters to i think to head office
in england both it would have been
signed by bradfield or not but he would
have drafted this correspondence.
We did have some contact with the local
officer. I believe in connection with
some of the granite blocks in
the parlance where i think
if i remember rightly. I checked some of
the courses to make certain that they
fitted in. All right. And i member rightly
on one occasion i found that they didn't
fit but i forget what happened about that.
I think gordon stuckey was probably away
at the time and i think when he came back
i pointed out to him and i mean probably
did something about all they may have
found out about themselves. But i by that
time and had just it it somehow. There
wasn't very very important thing i'm sure
but that was the only occasion that i
think i ever had anything to do with the
local office and. Well can i take you back
into your personal experience where were
you born. You know adelaide
and when on the 25th of may
nineteen hundred and
one in my parents home
where my sister and my last
surviving brother still live and
did you go to school in adelaide and it.
Yes i went to first of all what was then
called east at least
public school. Up until
i was about aged i suppose.
ten or eleven. Then
norwood district high school you member
your school days we are happy that
reasonably some why there were
some happy times and some not so
. But those were just
a high school when i first
went there it was just
in the same almost in the same buildings
as the primary school but they built
a new one at mcgill i think
it would have been. Which was
a good deal further away for me to travel
had to go by electric train that tram i
mean the mcgill line and that would
have been when i did what they
call their junior and senior public
examinations. They were carrying they were
slamming nations where external examinations
and their usually very big number of
students went into held i think at the
exhibition building you know adelaide which
is
a north terrace. And we used to go in there
and sit for them. I think i passed very
creditably in the junior one and i was i
think probably about the third or fourth
in the states in the senior one was willing
to work towards mathematics in those
days so many male matics.
After the senior exam.
There was another examination called the
higher you could on your pass from the
senior exam go to the university. But
there was no scholarship award and
on the senior there was
a scholarships to go to the university
awarded on the results of the higher. But
for the higher the only school which had
a class for the higher. Was the
adelaide high school. So i had
to go to the adelaide high school for the
last year. There are ten scholarships
given to the university and in the class
there would be about thirty
students when i went there and most
the ones where myself from all
the district high school. One or
two from only i believe and some other
high schools. And those that came
in that year i should mention that the
ones that were left there were probably
those that failed to get
a scholarship the previous year. They
were hoping to get it and they were very
annoyed when out of the chain
scholarships sward in that year that i
went to the ada high school there are six
i think least six of the ones that i've
just come in. So the poor cows that have
been sitting there for about some of the
couple of years. Try hoping to get
a scholarship to the university missed
out. But of the others for i would
probably say there were
three probably came from.
Free of four probably about cho them i
think probably came for some people's
college and probably one one or two from
sprint salford college. So one maybe and
then there was
a christian brothers college so i think.
There were about six from the end of
a school i think i was about the fourth
in the fourth of the in the chance. And i
think we had about six of the included that
gentleman the engineer i mentioned then
strike stein and another
one was kids duncan. And i
can't remember the others but some of the
others didn't do in generic they were
doing. Probably. One
restrict probably doing
medicine and i don't know what
else but there were certainly
a lot out of our particular year which
was very annoying to those who'd
had left behind and missed out. You know
your family was not pretty well off. You
know where you could have gone to university
with them paying. Oh they might have
but they much preferred for me to get
a scholarship. My father at
that time the editor had
a dad. But i say when i say it
it's perhaps i'm stretching it
a little bit because slenderman eisen
called himself the editor but my father
didn't say so himself. But we always used
to say that he did the work and selected
for the kudos. Would be the
grandfather i think of kim
who lost all your beautiful possessions
in the bushfire region to your read about
it. But living to sound.
I think kim would be
leaving some sun i think so. I'm not sure
about this but i think that would be the
case. And your father was did he retires
as the editor there or did you do
something. My father retired
about nineteen twenty. Or maybe
a bit more might have been laid. Later
that night in thirty. That's gone to you
your university years you went straight
from on to the university then and you go
straight into engineering you went
straight onto the university and he went
straight into engineering did you. That's.
Yes i said straight into engineering
although i spent an extra year after
i finished the engineering course
taking
a science degree and that was in melbourne
or that was in adelaide you know adelaide
adelaide. I know the words i had five
years at the university because of the
engineering course was
a four year course and i took an extra
year i had to pay if i remember rightly
part of the extra the scholarship didn't
cover me i had to pay for i think for some
of the extra subjects i had
to take in the last year for
a science degree. And
what was your first job
.
Well i think i didn't have a job for about
six or eight months and then there was
a free passage to england.
Was advertised on
certain british ships and i applied for
one of these free passages and about the
end of nineteen twenty three. I received
advice that i would have a
free passage to be granted
a free passage through to england and
return on the blue funnel line and the
ship. I went on was the n
e s and i got to england about. About
the middle of january. I think. 1924. What
was this. What sort of scheme was that
the offertory passages on the ship you
were supposed to go and do some sort of
study or job so shaded with your
profession that you chose and i
i had incidentally some cousins of my
mother's in london. Who organised.
Well this is the man.
The husband organised
a job for me with the marine engineering
firm in or just out of newcastle in
walls and on tyne. And i went there for
eighteen months doing mostly in the
workshops for
a couple of months in the drawing office
and was that was that marine engineering
or general engineering. Marine engineering
they were building marine steam and
diesel engines for ships and certainly
one of the only firms that had really
good work on their boards in newcastle
at that time echoes there was
a depression in the shipping
industry is that this was
a north and north east didn't marine
engineering company the director was
a troubled call summers hunter whom
i met not in their relation to
this is john hunter. I don't
know. Well it was a bit of
a gordon stuckey son also john summers
hunter. So don't hunter was to do with the
consortium which was trying for the bridge
contract. And apparently he was somewhat
irate that they were the to the didn't
get it. And he apparently he was. But oh
incidently you asked me what my first job
was while i was at the university the
adelaide observatory advertised for
students to assist with observations
of stars which were being
carried out by the observatory
in connection with
a world wide. Program to
try and fix. The position
of certain stars and this was being carried
out in connection with the program
which was being done in england and
i think also in south africa. And
i read. I'm not sure it
was one or two nights
a week and i had to assist in taking these
operate mainly reading the telescope
various. Results of the telescope.
After that than i used to take
they employed us several other university
on calculations in connection with this
and also we used to take. Star observations
for time purposes for us to check the
time and i used to go down
there one or two nights
a week to do this and this went
on after i left university.
I still had a one on one or two hours
a week on this which kept me in pocket
money while i was searching for
a job. Yes. Look we're number
of university students
that were also working there by the way.
And while you when you come back from
england was it was for public works your
first term. Yes that's right. I didn't i
was looking for again looking for
a job for some time without any success in
adelaide and then i was went to for some
reason i went talking to
a professor chapman one day and he suggested
what i told you before you were never
on the dole. I don't know where there was
a doll. I certainly wasn't on the
dole. I don't think there was
a dole nose days because during the depression
in the 30s i don't think anyone was
on the dole people just read
brown well without any. I
don't know what how they live. But i
don't think anyone got anything from the
government and those days it may have
been but i don't think so yes well i was.
Can you tell me about your subsequent
cria when you when you left the the
department of main roads you went in the
air force then you came out again what
bridges did you work on after that whether
when i you design bridges for most of
the rest you talk about the air force.
Now before you went on the air force you
were working for the department of main
roads again. And i went into the air force
but i didn't didn't actually leave
the main roads they sort of granted.
It's temporary leave of absence.
And my wife receives part of
my salary from the main roads and therefore
the fact what happened was i received
a certain salary from the
air force and it was
lower than my salary with the main roads.
But the main roads made up or at least
watch for
a while. Main roads by dup the difference
which they page of my wife after
i became
a squadron leader. I think my
salary was as much as my main road
salary and i. I think then used to pass
some of my money over to my wife because
you no longer received from the main road
that i was i think the case. I can't
remember exactly when you were in the
airforce when you first went in. What did you
do in the airforce what was your job. Well
i was very surprised that they didn't
put me onto engineering. But they put me
onto armament. And for eighteen months.
I first of all did
a course. On nor did an administration
of course first of all was about
a fortnight i think and then i did
a month or so of course on how much
point cook and then i went up to
and i think there's no one bags. There's
no one bombing and i think it's no one
bombing in school might have been number
two anyway it was the bombing and gun in
school. That's evidence head in the north
of new south wales. And believe me that
was
a home from home. Because until the
nips came into the war and then became
a little bit this happy but but that time
i was slightly slightly after that i was
transferred to amberley
where i was. Acting as
a cistern armament officer
for some months and became
a officer when after
the first officer left
but was transferred somewhere else and
then shortly afterwards i bet an engineer
that i had known and they said what the
heck are you doing on. Robby. And i said
well i don't know it's quite
interesting. He said we've got
a job for you and headquarters. So you know
i knew i was transferred to engineering
and air force headquarters and what sort
of engineering to do you do this mainly in
connection with the design and. Of
australian ect it built aircraft
and i worked under several
injured is but one
race an adelaide chap. You had no
training in aircraft engineering did you.
That's wrong. I did study
aircraft engineering as
a sideline when i was went to the main
road just before i went to the main roads
and i wrote a thesis on the design of
an aircraft which for which i received
a master of engineering from had
a university in one hundred thirty
five. I think. And i also taught
aircraft design and aerodynamics at the
sydney technical college for about
five or six years. Good just says you
know if you don't know. And so when you
came in the air force. I was
going to say well after the
more i gave away. All that
because i had too much work
to do on bridge designs much too much to
keep going. So my knowledge of modern
craft work. No mixers. Pretty
negligible. Which bridges. Did you
work on after after the war in
which bridges. Dozens of them but
the principal ones i suppose you could
say would have been the spit bridge. The
bridge over the hunter river at hexham.
This was an opening band bridge and so was
the spit ridge. And the
bridge over the hawkesbury
. Piece very numerous other
steel bridges and concrete
bridges known clearly. Steel bridge over
the clyde river at batemans bay and
that was an opening span bridge
and one over the clarence river.
At. Downstream from
grafton. I forget my spot.
Because they're all by the board now
because the maritime services board now
decided we had something years ago we
decided they didn't need opening spans and
none of those bridges. So it's all
a waste but the design of opening spanned
bridges it's quite fascinating. Really.
That what
a lot of work on that. And did you did you
do any work on the standard designs in
those days. Did the department have standard
designs at that time we had standard
designs for. Yes we had standard
designs for steel truss bridges for
steel girder bridges and for
concrete good bridges and i had
a lot to do with some of that work
too but after about 1950 or so
or even before that although i did
a lot of work on design and
i was put in charge of
a lot of bridge design and my
actual work on the sign was mainly
supervisory. That you get some credit for
a change. Wouldn't you. Well i
had some extra work on the day
through a bridge i did
a little bit of checking on that that
was not our design that was designed by
monsoor than partners
and we had the job of
having a look at it. Making
certain it was alright. And i did
a little bit of work on that
mainly checking up on the erection
. Looking back at the building of the
harbour bridge and the way it was organised
was that out of the ordinary you completely
out of the ordinary from your previous
past experience you know was the harbour
bridge. What's your impressions of it and
the way it was organized the design you
talk about the whole the way the whole the
way that it was organized in the
sense that it had a design section
a number of contracts who did the design
and you were supervising and checking and
every everything was checked and double
checked. Is this is correct. Isn't it. Well
. Since difficult questions you know initially
i didn't come on to until well after
the tenders had been accepted
and i didn't yet have
a copy of the report on tenders. From which
of which you probably see the copy i
don't know what you have but that
was very interesting because
i think mainly it was the work of gordon
stuckey and his chief of siders at that
time. Would be holton's powers. And
there they did
a lot of calculations on the various
designs and many cases showed
totally inadequate for the purpose
but for the. Site. One of them was
by steinman. And. Steinman
subsequently got very
peeved that they did his
design wasn't adopted. He made
a sneering remark in his book.
Regarding the harbour bridge
because the harbour bridge was. One
thousand six hundred fifty feet between
the arch pins. Now the words
the steel pins which support
the arch and the normally speaking you take
the spanners between the sense of those
pins one thousand six hundred fifty feet.
Now the americans designed the bridge for
the kill them. Carl crossing. And they
made its one thousand sixty six. Do you
hundred and fifty two feet four inches or
something like that. I can't remember the
stupid six something like that we're just
the idea of making it that much longer.
So they could say they had the longest
bridge the world who designed that fridge. I
don't know who designed it was and steinem
wasn't stein wasn't steinman no i don't
think this time i know but but he slunk off
an hour bridge saying oh the australian
people certainly people wanted to have the
longest arch bridge but they've slipped
out reckons got well we've got to bear in
mind that our harbour bridge is designed
for four lines of railways which are
very heavy load which. Never has had.
And it's got
a deck. It's i think one hundred thirty
two feet. Sorry i can't put that into
meters but the kelvin cal
bridge is only designed for
a relatively light road and it's
a very much smaller bridge in size than
the harbour bridge. So i think we can say
we got the greatest bridging if we
haven't got quite the longest one still
a spirit i mean it's known to refer to
as the heaviest heaviest certainly is
a lot heavier than they are that american
bridge but that's the bay bay on bridge
over the kelvin colors. That's right. The
bay on bridge that's the name of it. I'd
forgotten. I noticed that when you it's
something came to mind when you said that
was bridge was designed for four lines of
railway yes. Now. Do you remember doing
you all your testing. When they loaded it
up for with railway engines. Yes or yes
we took we took stress measurements
on the arch during that loading and
showed that the stresses were
quite within the allowable
. According to the specification
and my mention that the
locomotives which were used were
roughly speaking approximately. What
was a been
a maximum load you could have
expected from the railways
. If they had ever used
a way for what it was designed and what
the bridge was designed for was through
very heavy locomotives. But the very heavy
carriage was behind it. Yes there was
some argument about how many locomotive
because of course it's seventy two
locomotives and tenders and then it says
that some of them didn't have tenders so
they put extra locomotives on so i calculated
there was ninety six locomotives on
you can't remember how many there were no
i think my calculations fair enough. It's
just that people didn't read the whole of
the sentence. I just read the seventy six
. Seventy six railway engines on it with
tenders and then they stop there. Whereas
in actual fact the sentence 376 with
tenders. And then some didn't have tender so
they added extra elway engines. So you
know it's ridiculous thing around there. I
was had to scour around the place to get
some of those engines i believe it is true
i came across a man who had
to provide them. There's
a question re this loading of the of the
arch with railway engines. Is there
a precedent for that. Where were any
other bridges tested in that way. Oh i
understand that some bridges were but i
can't give you any detail that i don't know
whether they actually loaded the final
and successful bridge over the the st.
Lawrence river bank. Well i believe that
was loaded. You mean after the other two
fell down. That's right. Well i think that
was probably the reason why they decided
to have a put
a test. I wouldn't be sure of that but
i think that is the case. There is
a query here now i've done
a lot of research and read up to bradfield
and i heard tell that there was
a scientific experiment involved in this
which he was trying to to prove james
clark maxwell's theory on which the
the arch bridge calculations are
based in that in those experiments on the
bridge. Do you hear anything about this.
I can't comment on that one phrase i don't
know anything about that you didn't hear
anything about.